some of these I won't rehearse fully but
I will tell you where I put marks and so
on so here's part a part once and we
were asked to prove this a very standard
result okay so two marks the first mark
was for an appropriate choice of
substitution okay so you said you know
let let u equal and then most of you
chose this which is probably the most
straightforward way to say it so if you
let u equal to that then you can work
out D on DX which is negative one you
can work out in your boundaries which
are flipped upside down and it's no
dramas from there it's a very
straightforward thing to do the second
mark that I was looking for was after
you did the substitution and you put all
in and you formed your new integral okay
probably the most critical step with the
reversal of the boundaries I didn't
really pay all that much attention
because I didn't have much choice only
two marks to the change of variable
changing all the users back to X's I
didn't think that was such a big idea I
think this is more important and some
people even just very small not working
okay so we've got those two now the
reason why it's important to start there
is because you needed to use this part
properly to get part two now I know it
doesn't say hints or anything like that
but they're trying to lead you in that
direction and particularly when you have
a look at what they ask you to prove
this
and then you've got this which is i2
which has nothing to do with the
recurrence relations by the way they
were just using those in the technique
confused by it but still okay now I had
to smile to myself when I saw this
question because rumor I did not write
this paper right but I know that people
had specifically asked me I think almost
this exact question before I had seen
the paper or anything like that now it's
kind of did a silent yes you know I was
like you guys should be I mean there's
like there's a couple of little twists
and turns to do this but I had shown
them to you at least the people who
asked me okay um but still some of you
fell down I think probably the biggest
opening error was that you just didn't
use part one you don't have to use part
one to do it they don't constrain you to
do that but it becomes hard to do it in
other ways so here's the way that I did
it I started from I started from this
side over here I won okay and I said I
want to get to I - that's what I want to
do so all I did was I saw that this
thing here is built on what these
boundaries are a and B here they're not
Empire okay so all I did was I rehearse
the result from part one in part two
with these specific values that's all
okay so most of you your first line
should have been this okay boundaries
stay the same but everywhere I see X I'm
gonna replace it with the nor a plus PI
minus X because that's what a and B
correspond to in this particular
question
okay so I've gone next there so that
should be not plus PI minus X I've got
another one north plus PI minus X and
then I've got one last one here X okay
now at this point seven is you dropped
an easy mark
and I let me it was very strict but I'm
trying to communicate this to you so you
get this for next time and do it
properly if you wrote this but you left
out the zeros so you just write Y minus
X PI minus x pi minus X
okay very likely
you lost a mark there okay now you're
like really plus zero come on we know
that plus zero doesn't change it and I
love it it's a very very small
difference and I am than hard over
whether I would do it or not okay what
it came down to was if you pulled out
this line you need to connect it to the
result that you got it from right and
this result there's something there
right part - exit could be something
completely different I mean it could be
and some of you actually did this it
could be an identity that has to do with
this right with no lower boundary inside
okay
so I needed you to demonstrate that you
had gotten it from here and the cheap
way to do that was to say hey in this
case is zero it's an actual number right
it just so happens that it evaluates out
the only way you could get away with not
saying the zero and still get them on is
if you've done something like this if
you wrote it up without zeros squared
but if you had said over here from part
one you see this see this explanation
right this line here which you know most
people like I don't need to include that
this is the demonstration of
understanding now I can see where you
got it from right whereas if it's not
there if it's not there it could have
come from somewhere else right I know
it's to say it'll end up is the same but
the point is that you need to
demonstrate how you got there right it
is after all a show questions so you've
got to show the steps in the rationale
so I think that's a better line to go
with and then you simplify out okay now
there was the UM there was the first
mark I think for actually using that
part so there's this one there when you
do this most of you saw okay that's
really good I've got the PI minus X at
the front that I laughed up that's cool
all I need to resolve is these two guys
okay they had to be careful about the
way you did it
okay now I would say the best answers
not necessarily you didn't have to do
all of this to get from art but the best
response would say okay what can I do
here sine PI minus X what's that equal
to that's just equal to sine X right
okay and even if you didn't know that
identity you could see that you were
going there right but it's nice to
actually include that now at the same
time it's all got Maya PI minus X yeah
and now I've got sine X there this is a
tricky one a couple of you lost the
signal summer a small um you can't say
the same I've caused by mines X right
because cos PI minus X is not equal to
cos s right what's it equal to it's
equal to negative right you can look at
the graph and you can see it so
therefore if you went straight from here
to here yeah that was a bit dicey you
okay if again you'd actually said on
this side it's equal to negative so I
saw that you had used that correct
identity and then you squared out and
you just give the line of working that
was kind of okay but if you went
straight there without saying this it
doesn't make clear that you know what I
think is going on a better way to say it
within this because that squared applies
to the whole function so I think this
would be a better way to articulate a
million I need to say this it's clear
what it's equal to
okay so once you've gotten rid of that
double negative then you get to I - cool
yeah they're all right so just to
rehearse the first mark was here for the
use of Part 1 correctly and the second
mark was in the use of both of these
identities to actually get there okay